on va passer au buz du
jour et après l'eau de sonbain et les
culottes usagers Rubby nikara cette
influenceuse a décidé d'aller encore
plus loin en offrant un nouveau produit
vous allez voir le nouveau produit je
sais pas si vous allez l'acheter moi
pour l'instant je je je je je je
monsieur pas j'en ai pas senti le besoin
euh recherche de buzz ou vrai coup de
pub ou vrai coup de génie dites-nous ce
que vous en pensez ça fait ça a fait
énormément réagir sur les réseaux c'est
ce qui a fait le plus réagir là ces
dernières 12hes on regarde ça et on on
en parle juste après regardez elle sera
avec nous en plus ah bah très belle
photo bravo on y va merci le grand
gagnant du concours parce qu'on va
organiser un concours avec plein de jeux
des devinettes va avoir la chance de
recevoir donc ma coque personnalisée
dédicacé voilà avec un cœur très
personnalisé hein comme vous pouvez le
constater maintenant elle sent elle sent
les
boobs
voilà j'insiste bien pour qu'elle elle
s'emprunte bien de mon odeur hop
voilà maintenant elle sent également les
fesses voilà et donc du coup cette
personn va recevoir cette magnifique
cette magnifique coque qui le meilleur
gagne quel beau
produit merci Ruby d'être là salut ça va
ça va et toi salut va super salut tout
le monde Ruby alors comment as-tu eu
cette idée alors en fait juste on va
remettre les choses dans le contexte
parce que c'est juste c'est sûr que là
présenter comme ça non mais tu tu vends
vraiment des coques tu vends vraiment
des coques euh non je vends pas des de
coqu alors je vais juste expliquer un
peu d'où c'est parti donc en gros je me
suis dit pourquoi pas faire une
rencontre abonné un Meetup en fait ouais
Meetup et donc généralement un rencontre
une rencontre abonné en fait elle se
fait bah dans des lieux mais moi je me
suis dit pourquoi pas innover et faire
une rencontre virtuelle en passant par
un jeu vidéo et bah j'étais très
surprise par l'engagement parce que pour
le coup au bout de quelques minutes j'ai
rempli la salle en fait c'est une petite
salle que j'ai créé virtuellement et
j'ai reçu donc tous mes enfin
virtuellement voilà et et donc du coup
bah je trouvais ça impressionnant que
enfin je pensais pas que j'avais une
communauté autant aussi engageante et
j'étais tellement contente en fait sur
le moment enfin j'étais très contente et
je me suis dit bah pourquoi pas
dédicacer faire une coque dédicacée et
créer après tu l'idée et après tu as
l'idée de frotter cette coque sur ton
corps bah en fait enfin après c'est ma
personnalité je suis un peu excentrique
et je dit pourquoi pas me la
coque dans le cul en fait non mais c'est
ça en fait c'est ça c'est c'est ça en
fait en fait c'est c'est pas enfin je me
prends pas au sérieux en
fait après enfin c'est pas du tout je
compte pas commercialiser
ça juste un petit délire quoi cé juste
pour m'amuser ave rien
méchant d'ailleurs la coque je l'ai
envoyé au gagnant il a été très très
content avoir une pour un pote
pouron non mais bah là j'en ai pas mais
sinon je t'aurais passé une mais en gros
enfin voilà et du coup B tu dis beaucoup
ça c'est beaucoup de bruit pour rien
quoi bah là pour le coup c'était juste
c'est juste un petit délire que tu as
fait quoi parce que derrière ça étaé un
déferlement sur les réseaux sociaux
encore dès que tu fais un truc tout le
monde réagit y a Jean
Michel pour moi non non mais et donc
c'est vrai que ça a été un déferlement
sur les réseaux derrière non mais après
enfin c'est juste cé juste pour rigoler
bien méchant quoi qu'est-ce qu'est-ce
que est-ce que ça vous a interpellé V
Moon euh c un petit délire quoi moi déjà
j'aimerais juste qu'on qu'on sépare les
influenceurs de ta personne désolé mais
en fait je fais ce métier aussi
créatrice de contenu ou influenceuse et
en fait j'aime pas être associé à des
gens qui aujourd'hui malheureusement ou
heureusement je sais pas on te don
luenceuse ENIT d'accord bon ça me
rassure mais
alors derrière je me considère plus
artiste en je fais de la musique
notamment et puis bah là j'ai fait la
fassion week d'ailleurs ça fait tu as
fait quoi la fion week j'étaé invité par
des créateurs de haute couture des
marques de luxe avec qui je fais des
collabs et et donc voilà j'ai fait des
avec des marques de luxe invité sur des
défilés de mode tout moi j'ai jamais été
invité sur un défilé de mode je suis
dégoûté toi tu as été invité oui
pourquoi enin très un pe my sur les
bords quand même ah non du tout non bah
tu peux me suivre sur Instagram tu as
fait qu tu as fait quel défilé
[Applaudissements]
fait
mais tu as fait quel défi non mais
attends j'ai fait le festival Cino
France mode mode et culture mod culture
euh j'ai fait enfin après je suis pas là
non plus pour faire la promotion des
marques voilà mais du coup je comprends
pas tu es artiste de quoi mais elle fait
de la musique sort qu l'album elle rappe
tu sors des albums mais pourquoi du coup
on entend pas parler de ta musique mais
on entend parler de ton ton bain depr
c'est ma personnalité enfin je ou mais
c'est
Domis bah justement en ce moment je fais
tout pour pour m'éloigner du bad buzz
ouais après euh pourquoi tu es là
aujourd'hui pour parler de ça tu vois si
aujourd'hui tu es là c'est tu sais que
c'est pas pour parler de ta musique mais
pour parler justement de de
taisous fa personnalité qui est comme ça
et ça plaît à mes abonnés ça plaît à ma
communauté on me suit pour ça
doncjourd'hu je suis aussi en
divertissement donc r tu voudrais pas
nous faire un petit live la semaine
prochaine une petite chanson un live un
live on ouvre l'émission avec toi tu
fais un live de tout ce que tu fais
pourquoi pas faut qu'on AR j'ai vu j'ai
vu un son de toi qui était pas mal quand
tu es habillé en camouflage là en
camouflage je sais pas tuas une tenue
camouflage tu fais tu rappes bah en fait
à l'époque je faisais du son mais après
j'ai mis ça en suspens pour faire un peu
de l'influence du
coup ouais et donc du coup bah là je
reprends la enfin je reprends le son
mais plus artiste en
fait sil te plaî j'ai mis ça non j'ai
mis ça en suspend mais là je reprends la
musique ouais Moon tu as l'air tuas
l'airner non en fait c'est pas ça c'est
que bon après c'est rien contre
l'émission mais je trouve que maître en
lumière des gens comme toi pour ce genre
d'action alors que tu as des créateurs
de contenu qui font des trucs vraiment
formidables
y autre chose à découvrir aussi c'est
peut-être parce que tu ne me suis pas
c'est peut-être parce que tu me suis pas
les gens qui se fr d'accord très bien
mais oui mais là c'est sûr que si on
présente que ça c'est sûr qu'on peut se
dire ah mais elle est complètement mais
s que c'est que pour ce genre de chose
que tu es invité à parler et c'est pour
ça que je trouve ça même pour toi c'est
très dégradant en fait parce que enfin
moi pourprs il y a autre chose enfin
j'ai autre chose à proposer alors
propose comme voilà en ce moment je suis
passionnée par la mode en ce moment donc
je fais beaucoup de fait mal à personne
s' les gent g rigolent regardes
vidé jemich beaucoup j' de Jean-Michel
moi franchement je plutôt avec amusement
et pu sympathie parce que voilà c'est
une jeune elle s'amuse elle fait des
contenus elle fait des vidéos les gens
la regardent c'est pas de sa faute ça à
des gens
voilàais g mal à personne les gens
regardent pour se moquer
faut les gens regardent parce que ils
trou que R
tu quand on regarde les images on se dit
quand on regarde les images on se dit la
la peau enfin tu dois peut-être pas être
bien dans ta
peau pas par plus une VAN je CIS que
Gill veut défendre rubinara dans un
instant si g tu tu as Gill Jean-Michel
avec toi Sophie tu vois c'est est très
partagé
Pascal ça veut dire en gros si je suis
raisonnement je peux plus rigoler sur va
rigoler avec ma communauté le moindre
truc on va me tomber dessus on en fait
des
tonnes rien il a rien de bien méchant au
contraire le gagnant était très content
de recevoir ma coque avec mon odeur je
sens bon je porte quelques gouttes de
Chanel numéro 5 Ruby ENF c'est la co
ch mais c'est vrai le G était très
content de recevoir animateur parle ru
pard c'est quoi c'est ton vrai prénom
Ruby ouioui non mais si si bien sûr si
c'est mon vrai prénom mon père qui m'a
appelé comme ça ou te gen moi je
m'appelle émeraude en vrai Rubby nikara
est avec nous elle a un nouveau produit
sa coque de
téléphone est-ce que tu as vendu ta
coque de téléphone en tout cas en fait
c'est pas un nouveau produit enfin c'est
juste c'est parti d'un délire de base
voilà de base juste je remets les choses
dans le contexte tu mets l'église au
centre moi je suis très créatif donc du
coup ENF j'ai vu que personne faisait ça
des Meetup en passant par un jeu vidéo
donc je me suis pourquoi pas le faire et
pour que ce soit interactif pour que
voilà pour que ce soit enfin on passé
vraiment un très bon moment moi et ma
comunuté sur le jeu et pour interactif
je me suis dit bah pourquoi pas faire
des questions répones avec des
challenges et à la clé il y avait donc
cette co de téléphone après c'est
personnalis c'est ma coque coque à
l'odeur de
cul belle initiative après c'est ma
personnalité c'est j'ai toujours
été tu as besoin de faire ça pour
ramener plus de clients pour voir puiss
voir non pas du tout parce que justement
en en 2 3 minutesin j'ai rempli toute la
salle il y avait une liste d'attenteir
beaucoup plus de de vu alors Gill Verdes
qui veut prendre la défense de Ruby oui
oui vous avez du talent euh de l'humour
je dirais presque une lumière intérieure
ah ouais je pense que des gens comme
Hugo manos n'ont pas la capacité de vous
comprendre ils sont en retard sur
l'époque il sont en retard sur l'époque
et en fait je crois que vous avez
compris ce qu'elle époque c'est-à-dire
une instantanéité vous êtes vous-même
moi j'adore votre naturelle en fait moi
je suis là pour divertir mais oui
exactement Rubby pour divertir Hugo
malos il est incapable de comprendre ça
est inc il
aucun montenous ton cul ça va divertir
c'est ce qu' fait monttr-nous ton cul si
c'est ça divertir si c'est frotté c'est
une coque sur ses c'est pas TR habillé
ah non mais bon franchement tu tu t'es
sérieux Gill quand tu dis que ça ça
c'est pour la jeunesse c'est la lumière
tu présente Ruby c'est un dans l'époque
actuelle voilà
sa mais je suis pas éducatrice moi en
fait la vérité juste je suis pas pour le
fait que tout le monde se moque de toi
parce que je trouve que je suis pas
partis de ça j'ai PAsie mequer toi j'ai
juste envie qu'on distingue influenceur
créateur de
conduite ch ou mais c'est ça ta crainte
là mais tu sais pas très blessant dire
ce gen de moi je suis pas là pour me
moquer de toi mais pas du tout je veux
juste qu'on disue on pas non je me
sjà on se calme juste par tu prends un
peu de haut comm les cons c'est sû qu'on
en fait ça y estis je suis pas là je
suis pas là pour faire un buzz avec toi
déjà parce que moi j'ai pas du tout
cette recherche là et j'ai pas du tout
env d'
d'accord mais je t'inquiète pas reste
là-bas tu seras pas associé à
moi c'est tout ce que je veux juste
qu'on dis g ouais ça y est ça suffit
parce qu'il reste une place la moun ici
à
côté euh oui bonsoir non mais que moi ce
que je trouve assez brillant grave de
prendre les gens de haut comme ça non
mais bah si si je trouve que c'est assez
brillant che cot brillant jeune fille
non mais c'est qu'elle a fait une étude
de marché en fait quand vous avez vendu
vos petites culottes sales et quand par
exemple vous AZ vendu l'eau du bain
c'est qu'il y a forcément des gens qui
sont demandeurs de G
personne
acheté après cétait vous les avez
vendu après j'ai pas trop envie non plus
qu'on réduise à ça
sur
fait vous AZ
ça connaître
iiim apr je suis plus dans un dans une
direction artistique où là je suis plus
dans l'évolution on va dire oui donc
vous êtes spontané je grandis aussi
comme en fait je disons que quand on
voilà moi on me suit dans un parcours de
vie on peut faire des erreurs sauf que
voilà la différence c'est que je suis
exposé et les gens grandent grandit avec
moi et donc du coup bah voilà il y a des
moment que les G
exempleutre chose la musique la la
fashion we le truc de l'eauumain par
exle-ce que ça peut te faire qu'elle
soit allé moi je trouve çaant vous
parliez de lumière d'arti non mais elle
elle su elle suit
une c'est pas qu'elle
fait c'est qu' fait concernant c'est que
les gens achètent ce genre de truc
conc apparemment
je trouve ça nul je trouve pas ça beau
je trouve pas ça plais c'est t avis pas
PL à tout monde plus aprèsblige pas
voilà tout le monde peut pasê critique
littéraire tout le monde peut pas être
super tout le monde PE
pasilà son heureux c'est pas ça il y a
d'autres contenus qui peuvent être créés
on peut se creuser un peu la servervelle
pour faire
truc La Celle créa j'ai fait un Meetup
sur un jeu vidéo mais finalement en fait
moi en vérité j'ai rien contre toi euh
genre je veux dire que j'ai rien contre
ton contenu je dis juste que je trouve
ça dommage qu'aujourd'hui on mette
autant de lumière sur quelqu'un qui fait
ça plutôt que sur quelqu'un qui propose
un contenu un peu plus réfléchi un peu
plus innovant quelque chose qui c'est
innovant j'ai
j'ai et qui qui s'est froté sur in mais
quel chose quiel chose désolé c'est
innovant bah c'est innovant je suis
désolé mais au final les gens se moquent
de toi et moi c'est ça qui m'embête en
fait la vérité c'est pour toi j'ai pas
envie que les gens se moquent de toi je
préfère que tu sois chez toi et qu'il y
a des gens qui te suivent parce qu'
t'adore mais non parce que je me moqu de
to je veux pas qu'on m'associe à toi
mais parce que je mais ça c'est autre
chose je je veux juste te dire
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai pas envie que les
gens se moquent de toi parce que je
trouve que finalement si tu as des gens
qui te suivent c'est qu'il y a des gens
qui t'aiment et tant mieux mais je dis
juste que aujourd'hui j'aimerais qu'on
invite G qui sont pas là pour qu'on F
oui non mais je sais mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que ça fait plusieurs fois
que tu viens et que ça fait
un et qu'on vient finalement pour se
moquer
de ça fait plusurs fois
venez tout àitoit
d'cusez-moi moi je vous adore je vous
adore mais je vous le dis très
franchement les yeux dans les yeux vous
avez l'air
[Applaudissements]
jalous on on l' pas pour seelle parce
qu'il y en a plein qui sont d'accord
avec avec vraiment le plateau il est
très partagé ce so soutir de que
quelqu'un comme toi puisse soutenir ce
type de vidéo je trouve ça affligant
quel exemple c'est pour la jeunesse pas
un exemple pour la vieillesse non plus
toi ou je préfère l'exemple de MO tu
vois
excuse-moi exemple pour la JeanMichel
c'est pas un exemple pour la jeunesse
ENF pas qu'elle un exemple et nous on n
pas des exemples pour
la
VI pour
c'est y a ass il y a assez de rageux de
gens qui déversent de la ha c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon JeanMichel je a
assez de gens qui les verersent de la
haine des propos horribles sur Internet
elle elle fait mal à personne elle
s'amuse on la regarde on la regarde pas
on fait ce qu'on veut mais voilà c'est
ça ça sert aussi à ça les réseaux elle
prend son pied les gens s'amusent point
envie de la péch
quoi est-ce d'ailleurs est-ce que tu as
un fiancé de quoi est-ce que tu as un
fiancé tu as un mec euh non non ça m'a
pas l'air très clair tout ça non tu
c'est lib ouais ça ok très bien tu es
heureuse et j'aime bien tes cheveux gris
ah
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est bon mon frérot il va pas
tarder à se frotter sur une coque
celui-ci allez merci Ruby en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous merci ru
[Applaudissements]
merci